para decirle a una mujer que debe hacer
algo es anti feminista mucha gente nos
dice todo el tiempo cómo debemos ser o
comportarnos así que la pregunta en sí
misma va en contra de lo que creo como
feminista espectro convocamos a 6
mujeres para medir los niveles de sus
creencias y valores
les pedimos que expresaran su acuerdo o
desacuerdo respecto a algunas
afirmaciones sobre ser mujer
hace como cambiar un neumático 3 2 1
desacuerdo de acuerdo
o sea que hay una serie de pasos pero si
se presenta la oportunidad no creo que
tenga la confianza para hacerlo sabes
existen unas indicaciones por eso estoy
aquí y he cambiado mi neumático varias
veces no soy una gran conductora pero
tuve que aprender porque he reviento muy
seguido mi neumático
los niños y las niñas deberían ser
educados de la misma manera 3 2 1
no puede haber diferencias en las cosas
que aprendemos y que son importantes si
todos fuéramos educados de la misma
manera no habría tanta desigualdad todos
estaríamos en una misma posición así que
tal vez me cambie para no quiero tener
hijos pero si decidiera tenerlos
me gustaría que crecieran en un ambiente
en el que no haya diferencias entre
ellos él no tiene que aprender unas
cosas y ella no o viceversa estoy de
acuerdo pero creo que tenemos que vivir
en el presente y todos deseamos un mundo
perfecto y queremos criar a nuestros
hijos y decirles traten a todos por
igual sí absolutamente tratemos a todos
por igual pero reconozcamos que algunos
no piensan de esta manera si les
enseñamos a nuestros hijos la
responsabilidad que tienen ya que sean
honestos y no se aprovechen de alguien
vulnerable por eso estoy convencida de
que hay que enseñarles a los niños a ser
hombres y también a las niñas a ser
mujeres
toda mujer debería ser feminista
y yo creo que el feminismo en los
últimos años se ha vuelto extremo como
en los 60 en esos momentos si eras
feminista entonces daniela hombre
hombres en serio y me entiendes que
serán de hombre creo que deberíamos
incorporar a los hombres para que puedan
apoyarnos
en la conversación y creo que ahora
mismo el feminismo dice no los
necesitamos hoy es un error no con eso
pero también creo que a las mujeres
hemos sido tan menospreciada que tenemos
que ser radicales e ir en la dirección
opuesta solo para que podamos llegar al
medio porque de lo contrario los hombres
no se encontrarán con nosotras ahí pues
bueno el feminismo en sí mismo es la
idea de que tomar decisiones por ti
misma y lo que te impulsa y decirle a
una mujer que debe hacer algo es anti
feminista
porque mucha gente nos dicen todo el
tiempo como debemos ser como
comportarnos como vestirnos hasta cómo
comunicarnos así que la pregunta en sí
misma va en contra de lo que creo como
feminista
agregó que el aborto debe ser legal 321
aquí vamos hola
y creo que es circunstancial es evidente
que hay casos en los que la madre puede
sufrir un daño considerable durante el
parto en mi opinión en este caso ese
aborto estaría bien no tengo otra
excepción serían los casos de violación
pero en los demás escenarios estoy a
favor de la vida todos merecemos una
oportunidad de vivir estoy de acuerdo
contigo pero también soy consciente de
las imposiciones del gobierno al dictar
lo que podemos hacer con nuestros
cuerpos y eso es irritante luego vemos a
personas que tienen hijos y son
infelices el resto de sus vidas porque
criaron a niños que nunca quisieron es
frustrante y crees que esos padres que
tienen dificultades para criar a sus
hijos no tuvieron la opción de darlos en
adopción o algo así depende porque para
muchas culturas la adopción no está bien
así que no podrían hacerlo
no me importa que los extraños coqueteen
conmigo
hey caballerosidad tú eres la palabra
que me viene a la mente disfruto el
piropo de un caballero me gusta algo así
bueno eso es cierto
si se admite está bien pero no hay forma
de saberlo previamente todas tuvimos
malas experiencias de coqueteo pero
también recuerdo que he tenido algunas
como disculpa quiero que sepas que eres
muy hermosa y que tengas buen día y yo
digo está bien ya sea me la dio así que
es corto y dulce y no hay expectativas
de eso se trata en mi caso yo soy de
nueva york y siempre estoy en automático
es como no me hables no me mires toda mi
vida he recibido piropos pero algunos se
convierten en acoso así que si no te
miro si no te hablo soy una mala persona
y me pregunto si te contestará entonces
que sería no creo que todos los chicos
sean la no lo sé no es tan fácil que lo
son si no podemos asumirlo y no es una
buena manera de vivir obviamente bueno
entonces mi pregunta es a 15 lo
aceptamos
y como sabemos a quién se lo aceptamos y
cómo funciona en tan sólo empezar en la
relación de una manera no romántica o
sexual sino como un acercamiento si es
una persona hasta conocer a otras
personas y poder conversar y que te
hablarán como una persona normal apoyo
al movimiento mitú
en el fondo creo que el movimiento michu
se trata de las mujeres que han estado
en situaciones de trabajo personales y
que no han tenido un espacio seguro para
hablar o compartir y de nosotros depende
que estos casos salgan a la luz y no
seguir protegiendo al agresor lo que
está pasando es muy grave es traumático
para cualquiera caballo experimente sacó
un terrible acoso sexual y esto sucedió
en 2013 pero todavía no he hablado de
ello si usted estadísticamente el número
de mujeres que son violadas es
exponencialmente mayor que las que
realmente lo denuncian así que cuando
estoy pensando en este movimiento meet
why en su en unión cuando todo esto
empezó me dije no sé si quiero hablar
sobre esto no sé cómo me siento pero me
di cuenta de que en realidad sí podía
compartirlo con alguien más escuchando
las me doy cuenta de que la razón por la
que no
y en esa línea es más porque cuando
michu comenzó no tuve la fuerza o el
coraje de ser parte de él en mi mente es
como ya saben como si yo no tuve el
coraje de ser parte de eso y aún no
tengo el coraje de estar en esa línea
porque es como admitir que he estado en
esas situaciones saben entonces y
representando a todas esas mujeres que
sienten lo mismo y ellas son capaces de
empatizar contigo estás ayudando a otras
mujeres diciendo eso sí
creo que el mundo sería mejor si
estuviera dirigido por mujeres 321
habría diferencia habría si digo que el
mundo sería mejor si lo dirigiera en
hombres si vamos a decir eso desde aquí
no sería justo eso no es para nada
equilibrado lo que pienso al respecto es
que en el estado en el que estamos justo
ahora debemos hacer esfuerzos por llegar
a un lugar donde podamos criar a los
hijos de la misma manera y que las
mujeres no tengan miedo de salir y que
los chicos no cultiven una masculinidad
tóxica entonces cualquiera podría
dirigir el país y todo estará bien
porque todos seríamos iguales para ahora
mismo en el lugar en el que estamos las
mujeres tienen una mejor perspectiva de
eso pero es difícil porque sabemos que
hay niños y ellos no son responsables ni
deberían serlo de las cosas que otros
hombres hicieron sean sus padres o sus
abuelos porque deberíamos dirigir el
mundo es la misma situación que hubo en
los años 50 a las niñas de 7 años se les
dijo que los hombres asumirían los
poderes tal vez si tuviéramos más
mujeres en el liderazgo en el en el en
el congreso si tuviéramos más mujeres en
posiciones de poder no necesariamente
dirigiendo el mundo pero si sólo
tuviéramos más
a mujeres de color con diferentes
orígenes si tuviéramos más inclusión en
el liderazgo en todo el mundo sería un
lugar mejor
yo me ubiqué aquí porque no creo que
deba ser una o la otra solo pienso que
cuando son una parte domina el resto de
la sociedad se diluye si el mundo o
cualquier gobierno o liderazgo no
funcionaría si no somos capaces de
incluir a la otra mitad creo que el
problema con lo que algunas personas
piensan que es el feminismo es que creen
que tienes que hundir a unos para apoyar
a otros pero no tienes que hacer eso se
puede elevar a las mujeres a posiciones
de poder sin que denigre moss a los
hombres y creo que esa es una idea
errónea del feminismo
un abrazo de grupo vamos necesito entra
aquí
[Risas]
hola chicos hoy tendrá muchas gracias
por vernos si les gustó asegúrense de
suscribirse y seguirnos en instagram
dejar un comentario y nos vemos en la
próxima
you believe